what's up everyone Matthew and Sina here
and today I'm gonna show you guys how to
make this abstract surreal collage image
that we've been making for our channel
on the future I've been making a bunch
of the thumbnails for all the videos and
I just wanted to break down this image
and show you guys step by step how I
came to make one of these things first I
want to talk about the concept the
concept here was based off of a video
that Chris had made for the channel and
it was this two minute challenge and it
was called limiting beliefs unlocking
unlimited so the idea in the video is
that you take these words that have a
negative association or connotation for
you and you flip them by giving them a
new meaning so I wanted to create some
kind of image that would convey that in
an interesting way and become a dynamic
image for the thumbnail so I came up
with this and the idea is that I was
thinking of when I thought of that
concept was retraining your brain
unlocking so it's thinking about keys
and locks and then I'm also thinking
about what that means for you that it's
just like opening up something different
there's transformation so this is my
thought process as I'm thinking about
conceptually what the video is about and
what it needs to convey and these go
into what I'm considering when I'm
looking for images so getting into this
I want to search on some stock websites
and I was looking for a couple of things
let me pull open bridge here so you guys
can see that first I started with the
brain right because that was my first
thing that I was thinking about so I was
looking at heads just silhouettes and
then literal brains because I was
thinking maybe I could have some kind of
brain and maybe it's like opening up or
changing colors or something it's it's
trying to transform maybe there's a key
that triggers and unlocks your brain and
then I found this very cool image as I
was doing my stock search when I saw
this this became the anchor of what I
was thinking of developing
so Michael was to take this as the key
image and combine that with something to
do with the brain so if I go back to my
brain catalog at first I was thinking
maybe goes with this brain image but the
problem with this is that this image is
positive in terms of this is a white
value a light value here and this is a
dark value here and if we go back to the
other image this negative space right
here is white and the positive space is
black so it would be very difficult for
me to combine those two things so then I
found this image this illustrator file
right here I'm gonna take the
silhouetted guy and I'm going to go into
Photoshop I'm gonna start a new document
in a pastéis as a smart object right now
so it retains the vector data there so I
can scale this up and it's not going to
lose any detail I'm gonna push tab to
bring up my other menus and then before
anything I'm gonna start naming my
layers little tip here make sure you
name all of your layers and never leave
anything untitled or at least try not to
and I'm gonna go back to my assets and
I'm gonna pull this image right here
this one with this man pushing the wall
down I'm gonna drop this right on top of
the head here I'm gonna turn down the
opacity because what I'm gonna try and
do is see where these things are going
to line up so more or less I want it to
line up here because I want this to feel
like this little character right here
he's pushing down this barrier this wall
and he's unlocking the path to this new
way this new positive way of thinking
right just like the concept in the video
so I'm holding option and I'm clicking
between this so it will just only apply
it to this layer that's pretty cool now
it's silhouetted right there it's
looking pretty rad problem is look the
image ends right here and I have this
goofy space which I don't like let me
just make a new layer and I'm gonna
this patch and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take the clone tool clone stamp
this is what I'm looking for boom so
what the clone stamp does is you sample
a section which I'm going to sample this
guy right here
I'm gonna turn this off real quick and
turn off the screen I just want to focus
on this layer only so if you look at the
settings for the clone stamp I'm just
gonna change it to current envelope so
this layer envelope so the way this
works is I'm gonna sample a section
we're gonna hold option right here or
alt select that section and now I can
create a patch with that same thing you
see how that works magic it's alright if
I'm a little sloppy here and just you
see now I created this cool extension of
what was above but the problem is you
see it feels like I got a little bit of
his leg and it totally feels like it was
just clone stamp I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take other areas and I'm gonna
start burying it and just start patching
this up a little quick so I'm just
pulling different areas just mixing and
matching so it doesn't feel so stampy
and I'm just trying to hide the seams as
much as possible I don't need to get too
caught up in details here because I
could always come back and add more so
I'm you know full command II so now
they're part of the same layer they're
one layer call this keyhole and then
apply it only to the head right there
see that now it feels like we got this
seamless bit right here okay so I think
I have the center the anchor of my image
so the next thing I want to give this a
more interesting background I downloaded
a bunch of these cool paper torn assets
just for textures back in the day when I
was in college I made a lot of these by
hand I would just take a bunch of scraps
and rip them out of magazines paste them
on something either scan them or
photocopy them over and over and over to
get these very very cool textures and I
used to carry a harddrive maybe a 200
gigabyte hard drive of just textures and
it was very very fun to make but
nowadays I have more resources than I do
time so I just go to stock sites and I
purchase these things because it's a lot
easier for me to do but highly
encouraged a lot of you guys just to
make this on your own just for the fun
part of the process okay now what I'm
looking for is just something that's a
little textural that's going to give me
something interesting in the background
so some of these are very cool with
seeing these types and letter forms
behind it I think they're ultimately too
busy for this thing because I don't want
to break the silhouette of
head I want to keep it relatively simple
so I'm gonna pick this guy right here
and it looks like this is just like
white paint over black or vice versa
and what I want to do is for someone to
move it down a layer and then I'm gonna
scale this up right now I'm just looking
at the positive and negative values
because I'm trying to break this thing
up a little bit like maybe it's kind of
cool on the shoulder so this is cool but
the problem is you can see that values
are just pretty much the same here so
I'm gonna go up to image and adjust and
I'm gonna adjust the curves on this
texture it here so you can see there's
no black values here so I'm just gonna
bring this curve down down so we're
starting to get some black in the
background right there now we're getting
more separation on this guy you know
pedal the mill mid values down actually
getting to blast the white values up a
little bit because I want those to
remain relatively flat now this very
deep s-curve here especially in both the
low values and then put okay so this is
pretty cool but I want a little color so
I'm gonna name this first BG texture
whenever you see BG mg or FG those are
little acronyms I use for a foreground
mid-ground and background so color wise
I want to pick something that's pretty
bright and red you can see I kind of
have something sampled already but
really I'm a sucker for this persimmon
color where it's very orange with a lot
of red in it
background okay so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take this color layer
put it underneath my BG texture I'm
going to change my BG texture to screen
so it's just going to take the light
values and screen that on top of the
color layer okay so now I can move this
around even though I like the shape
before can i light this deep red back
here I'm just looking at this from a
formal standpoint what's gonna make my
eye move around the canvas a little bit
and I kind of like this wavy line going
up in a diagonal I could also try it and
see what happens
if we make this a little bit more
straight I'm not a fan of these values
up here in this left and right corner
they're a little distracting so let me
see if I could paint those out push B
for brush and I'm going to make this
full opacity now all I'm doing is I'm
just patching out and I'm painting the
areas where I don't want these somewhat
distracting textures and lines and
shapes I think for the head I'd like to
make the values of this darker because
if we do this this is a little trick I
do sometimes I'll take a human
saturation put it right at the top and
they'll turn into saturation all the way
down and I just study the values and
what I'm seeing is that the value of the
background is still very close to the
value of this head right here so if you
squint your eyes it's it's hard to fully
read the silhouette here so the way I'm
gonna do that is I'm going to select my
head group here and I'm gonna create
curves again with option and click
between the layers so now my curves are
only going to apply to this head right
here I'm going to take the dark values
on this curve and I'm going to bring
them down I'm also going to bring down
the mid-tone values and I'm just now I'm
just looking at the silhouette
the head I don't want to bring their
family even the white values I kind of
want to bring that down they're a little
too intense because I want the street is
one silhouette and I want to reserve
most of the light values for this
background in this keyhole right here
and I know what you're thinking you're
like well dude now that keyhole looks
like crap doesn't look that good cool
thing is it comes with a mask right here
so you just use black and white values
to paint in or out where you want that
effect so I'm gonna use a I'm gonna push
B for brush and I'm gonna use the black
value to paint this part back in
actually he's adding this cool little
like a glow effect almost right it feels
like the light is coming out of this
cavity inside this guy's head I want to
add a little bit more dimension here so
I want to add another object in the
scene as I was mentioning earlier I was
thinking about the concept of what
images came to mind and this image came
to mind this key because I was thinking
about keys unlocking locks so naturally
I was looking for a vintage looking key
because I thought this is super cool and
I'm gonna go to my selection tool by
pushing W this is the magic wand tool in
Adobe Photoshop 2019 they have this cool
thing or you could just click the Select
subject and it's super smart look boom
it already knows what I'm looking for
that's my key and I'm gonna click this
button down here and make a layer mask
there's this key that feels like it's
unlocking this guy's and brain flip
horizontal so maybe it's you know
leading us cuz I like this angular line
where this key is leaving us visually
towards the keyhole next thing I want to
do is because this is a paper collage
style I want to make it feel like this
key is actually something that was
printed on a piece of paper or from a
magazine and we cut it out so there's a
couple ways to do that the way I'm gonna
use right now is I'm gonna go to my
effects here I'm going to add stroke
wherever is that Oh yep I'm gonna add a
stroke here and I set this to the
outside it's not quite what I want but
you know I'm gonna start right here
so I'm making a layer behind the key and
I call this paper fill and now I'm gonna
push L for the last cell trying to make
it feel like I use broad scissors and
just fill this in like I want to
preserve some of the nice details that
were cut out from the magic wand and the
stroke that I added on the outside but I
want to give this a little bit more
natural imperfection we're gonna fill
that in so now have this cool paper cut
out key what I want to do is only give
that a little bit more dimension so I'm
gonna add a little bit of a drop shadow
effects and a drop shadow cool I got a
little dimension from this keyhole here
this face is standing out from the
background you know maybe we make the
face feel like it's being pushed back a
little bit more so I'm going to go to
this head layer right here I'm gonna go
to effects no no I'm gonna go to insert
inner shadow an inner channel original
want to give a little bit of shadow on
the edges going in so it feels like this
is actually protruded back from the red
background that we have here so very
very subtle things here just to give us
more depth I think we can move into
finishing touches now because this is a
collage and want to make this feel very
tactile less tactile
as possible so if I go back to bridge
I'm gonna go to this folder here called
paper textures downloaded just a few
paper textures usually what I like to do
is take one of these and put it over
everything just so it feels like
everything has a nice tactile feel to it
it's going I'm gonna set this to
multiply and you can see right away it's
adding some really cool details across
the board and that's looking pretty nice
so this is good just for an overall look
but what I actually want to do is add
some specific textures to this key this
cutout key here I'm gonna use this paper
texture down here
this in and hold the option and have it
just apply to that key or anything first
I'm going to set it to screen but you
can see that layer is just so bright
right now so I can do a couple of things
and I'm gonna invert it command I it's
adding the slightest amount of texture
to that but it's all of these subtleties
that adds up that make it feel a little
bit more real I think I'm pretty happy
with this you have the key that's
bringing us in visually from the top
right corner of the frame leading us at
this keyhole which you realized as the
silhouette of this guy's head and then
you see this little character as the
last Reed who is pushing the barrier
down unlocking his mind which is the
concept of the video that Chris made
unlocking your limited potential so
that's the tutorial hopefully you guys
were able to follow along if you have
any questions make sure to put it in the
comments section below and don't forget
to give us a like and subscribe I'd love
to do more of these types of videos but
only if you guys are paying attention
and if you guys value this type of stuff
let us know and if you guys are
interested in learning more about how to
master Photoshop photo compositing and
how to make very dynamic frames that
tell stories consider taking my style
frames course which I've put in the
description below alright guys that's it
I will see you guys on the next episode